let's go next to our caller from the
8:32 area code who's calling today from
eight three two hey David my name is
rich I'm here in Texas and I'm actually
running for the State House of
Representatives down here and I'm 28
years old with young person and actually
you know I just gotta say you're one of
the reasons I got into this I kind of
[ __ ] my policy around listening to you
for so long but Wow all that being said
you know you know thanks yeah so I'm I
do have a question for you so I'll be on
six months ago yes we should being in
Texas were being a Democrat it's a very
delicate process
you know the idea of Bernie being the
nominee was worrisome I'll be honest and
starting to change my opinion a lot over
the last couple months I mean even down
here in Texas I think he's got a good
shot at winning the primary at the very
least but I won't tell you mean places
like Fort Bend County which went blue
for the first time in decades in 2018
and actually was working on a
congressional race down here so a lot of
the folks that voted Democrat to the
first on many years and live a part of
that suburban blue wave I still you know
I'll be honest I mean I still have this
concern that Bernie being the nominee is
gonna maybe not maybe not get those
folks out to vote maybe they'd vote back
for Trump again but I tell you they came
on voting just got to their pure disgust
for Donald Trump and while that was good
for us in the short term I worry
long-term how are we gonna keep those
voters so I'd love to hear your thoughts
on that and and again yeah thank you for
doing what you do have always been a
huge thing to you well listen I
appreciate the kind words here's the
thing if you want to talk about voter
turnout there's no question that a lot
of Elections including most likely the
one in November it's going to hinge not
on who changes their mind but more on
who decides to get out and vote so the
question of which candidate will
mobilize versus restrain different
groups from choosing to vote or getting
that mobilizing them to vote or dissuade
them from voting it's a very relevant
question but the problem is if you want
to slice and dice it so thin we'll never
get anywhere in the and what I mean by
that is the following it's very
plausible that there is a part of Texas
where they don't like Trump but if
Bernie's the nominee they just want vote
or they might vote for Trump I
I grant that that's probably true but
then there's also probably a part of
Wisconsin where if a centrist Democrat
is the nominee
they'll stay home even though they don't
like Trump but if a progressive is the
nominee they will come out and vote so
once you start trying to slice and dice
how turnout will be affected in really
narrow areas like part of a state it
becomes impossibly complex and so my
view is we should step back a little bit
we should at the top level make sure
we're running a primary that is not so
damaging to the candidates that it will
hurt whoever the eventual nominee is
right that's a top level thing number
two let's make sure that the DNC is not
seen as a dishonest broker of the
primary which could get people to vote
for Trump merely out of anger or to stay
home so my thinking about turnout is
more big picture than about like well
what will happen in Hampton County
versus Hampshire County Massachusetts if
Bernie versus Biden are the nominees
because if there's too many factors we
can't possibly account for all of them
with that kind of thinking well I tell
you I probably cement so the the main
concern here is so the Texas State House
is under if you're aware this were only
nine seats away from the first
Democratic majority yeah 18 years so
after rainbow and we put 12 seats in
2018 I don't think anybody saw that
coming in these nine seats they all came
very close last time around so I'll be
honest I mean I think Trump is probably
gonna win Texas in November probably
yeah maybe but that being said image we
want to talk about long-term gains many
places like Texas places like you know
Virginia where they flip their
Statehouse in other states to where
we're seeing these margins in the
Statehouse LaVon if you want talk about
gerrymandering obviously a concern over
the next decade I mean I think I do
think it's something that we need to be
thinking about I don't hear enough from
Bernie about down ballot momentum I hear
from you know Joe Biden talks about the
Senate a lot obviously that's important
went back to Senate but I do think a lot
of these state legislatures and one of
the reasons we're in this mess is
because you know folks like the Koch
brothers spend millions of dollars
actually not even that much I mean low
millions over the last 20 years to flip
these state ledge seats and that's
allowed up ballot momentum for
Republicans across the country and I
think we really touched Democrats we
need to be aware that I really think the
state houses around the country needs to
be the key to its
at least providing a fair playing field
for the next ten years no question state
houses gerrymandering the census
redistricting a voter suppression all
super important stuff and we'll do our
best to keep covering all of it rich I
appreciate the call thank you so much
rich from Texas great to hear from you
let's take a quick break if you're
holding on the phones don't hang up
because we will go right back to the
phones after this short break